lazo acepta La derrota el presidente de
Ecuador se pronunció frente a los
resultados de las elecciones seccionales
del pasado domingo 5 de febrero unos
comicios en los que los Ecuatorianos
eligieron gobernadores municipales y se
votó un referendo impulsado por el
gobierno que pretendía reformar la
Constitución entre más políticos
institucionales y medioambientales pero
que no obtuvo los resultados esperados
Ecuatorianos cuando el pueblo habla es
deber de los gobernantes
analizar entender y aceptarlo
Acepto que la mayoría no esté de acuerdo
que esos temas Se resuelven con las
herramientas puestas a consideración en
el referéndum durante la misma jornada
electoral el expresidente e izquierdista
Rafael Correa y su nuevo Movimiento
Político Revolución ciudadana obtuvieron
una sorpresiva victoria ganando las
prefecturas de provincias y 60 alcaldías
del país incluidas las ciudades de Quito
y Guayaquil así como decenas de
concejalías y juntas parroquiales a
pesar que las encuestas apuntaban a
resultados diferentes el correísmo logró
consolidarse y resurgir después de casi
seis años en el olvido desde algún lugar
de Ciudad de México donde reside Correa
Desde que la justicia ecuatoriana la
condenó a 8 años por corrupción el
exmandatario celebró los resultados por
medio de redes sociales
es una victoria histórica acabamos con
la hegemonía de la derecha en guayas
inicia una nueva época para recuperar el
Ecuador desde los territorios junto a la
gente que sabe que antes estábamos mejor
con estos nuevos resultados corre ave
más factible la posibilidad de volver a
presentarse en las elecciones
presidenciales del 2025 para un posible
cuarto mandato